uh it's been a process
um obviously thankful for you know the
support you know I had during this time
obviously it's not easy you know not
being out there on the floor and you
know having to watch but um you know
with everything else you know being
around the team being able to practice
being able to travel um you know the
guys just constantly you know uh talking
to me and you know vice versa uh it's
been good
so Jo what would you say during this
time or some of the main things that you
know you've learned and kind of
reemphasized for yourself during this
stretch uh I pretty much just been you
know focusing on me um honestly um
outside of you know the basketball stuff
um but you know basketball-wise just you
know becoming more of a leader you know
with my talk obviously you know it's
different when you know you out there on
the floor and you you not so it's not
too much I can say Obviously you know
I'm not you know out there in the fire
with them but um you know as much you
know coaching or things I see um I just
tell
them Adam Silver mentioned that he was
going to have what he call a check-in
with you uh what was that conversation
like what what's kind of the what was
his main message to you uh it was good
um he was just you know checking on me
see how I was doing um how the process
was going um pretty much
that J after the the ouster by the uh
Lakers you talked about needing to make
better decisions off the court uh in the
last few months since mid June how Are
there specific things you've done to
help yourself maybe try to to grow in
any particular areas uh just protecting
my
peace hey John know you Superstar and
all like that but you you you first came
back how soon can people expect you to
be back to midseason form I know you
shouldn't expect the first game because
it's going to take your time to get up
so how long should it take you to get to
where you should think you should
be uh hopefully you know it it do be the
first game but you know
obviously um you know it's different
when you're actually you know in the
game um getting game reped so um I'm
just try to come back you know do
whatever I can uh to help the team win
you know I'm not forcing you know a a
historic game you know my first game
back um you know I'm just super excited
to be you know back out there with the
team J um basketball's been your life
how hard has this process been of the
last few months it's it's all you really
have ever known how hard has this been
to be away and kind of being excited now
that just you're a few days away from
getting back to what you've always done
uh it was definitely tough um
some horrible days you know um it it was
tough but like I said you know to you
know start this um you know with the
support you know that I had you know
throughout this process it you know it
definitely helped me a lot um it's
pretty much you know all all I could
lean on you know at that time you know
obviously you know basketball is you
know like you said something I've been
doing you know pretty much my whole life
something that's you know therapeutic
you know for me um obviously you know
taking that away it makes it tougher but
uh like I said I had you know the right
people around me from my family to the
organization uh and to my other partners
that you know help me along this process
John do you have um a message to the
fans who are eager to see back out on
the court and U what have you learned
from this process you know just
personally and
professionally uh I feel like my only
message is you know I'm just as excited
to you know see them um you know when
that time comes
um
yeah ch right here uh back in kind of
that September time time frame uh your
team put out some videos accountability
on shirts rebirth gratitude um why were
some of those things themes that you
felt like were important to you and
important to put out um it's pretty much
just something you know uh we had to sit
down and talk you know amongst each
other um just you know a word that you
know each um one of us you know came up
with that you know we felt like could
help me get through um to send a message
um and you know they decid to surprise
me with you know t-shirts of the words
that you know uh we pretty much agreed
on so um that's all that was pretty much
behind
it there's the first incident in March
you took time away to work on yourself
and then despite that what happened in
May that led to the suspension still
happened why should people believe that
the changes you made this time are long
lasting and sustainable uh I can't you
know make nobody believe me outside of
my actions so U me answering this
question was just words probably won't
mean nothing to
nobody two questions one just following
up um what does protecting my peace mean
what does that look like what do exactly
what does that mean um just doing
whatever you know I feel like that you
know keeps me happy you know keep me in
a good mood um right now honestly I feel
like the number one thing outside of you
know being around my family um and you
know having you know more time to you
know spend with my daughter is you know
being around the team um I feel like
that's you know when I normally have my
best days when I'm normally in my best
mood so um Coming days hopefully you
know I'd be you know even happier when
you know it's a consistent thing and
then there's a lot of people whether
it's written or spoken who have said who
have told you or told the world like
what you've done wrong I'm curious what
do you think what mistakes do you think
you've made throughout all this this
last year or so if any like when you've
reflected what do you what do you think
you've done wrong if anything or do you
not think you've done anything wrong I
made a lot of mistakes you know not
something that's even been public you
know even with my family um it's a
lot hey J talk about how this process
has been man a lot of self-reflection
counseling talking to people spending
time with yourself just talk about how
it's been over the last couple of
months uh basically picking back and off
you know the things I said earlier it's
been tough um you know a lot of learning
um um a lot of teaching uh it's been you
know a process you know obviously I
wouldn't say you know uh I regret it but
I'm you know not happy that it happened
um but I'm also you know grateful that
you know I had this opportunity to like
you said reflect um and do things that
you know I felt like was not only needed
for me but you know for my family you
know as well for us to you know realize
pretty much you know what's all at stake
you know um ways you know we can you
know keep each other happy um and you
know how we just you know have each
other's back I feel like we obviously
been close before but we came together
you know even more you know during this
process is it has it been as the losses
have piled up has it been has that part
of it been painful and is there a part
that makes you feel like you're somehow
responsible or at least in part
responsible for that yes there
definitely um you know some guilt in
that obviously I'm not on the floor um
and obviously nobody likes losing so you
know our job is to you know go out there
and get a win um I take full
responsibility of that um obviously even
though I'm not on the floor you know um
decisions I made didn't allow me to be
out there you know to go to battle with
my team
so how have you watched the first 23
game how have you watched the first 23
games so far and what is your evaluation
of the team as you have been watching
them on television uh it's pretty much
how it's been film study for me you know
obviously you know I've been with you
know majority of the players for a while
now obviously we got some you know New
pieces so um you know me being you know
the point guard that's you know guys I
have to you know learn and you know find
out you know where they want to be on
the floor um as far as you know where we
stand um I'm not you know worried at all
um obviously you know we have guys out
but um I feel like we've been preaching
over the years you know that next ManUp
mentality
um I'll say you know I don't think it'll
be long before we find it um I feel like
we taking strides you know in the right
direction um as of now as of late and I
feel like the only way for us is to go
is up
so with that being said um with that
being said job what do you think what's
your level of optimism as far as like
get into the plays playoff Etc what do
you think about the play of jiren
Jackson Jr in Desmond Bane since you've
been away I mean the playoffs and
playing is you know a while from now so
you know like I said um you know before
you know I take it day by day um I feel
like you know each day we can get better
at something whether you know even if
it's a off day we're taking care of your
body or watching film com to practice
the next day a shoot around or a game um
just having our Focus you know on the
now uh and as far as you know um those
guys in their level of play um I
obviously feel like you know those guys
playing at a
Allstar level all NBA level um and when
I come back hopefully you know it stays
the same and you know it just makes
their job you know even
easier Jo how is it for you to have
Dereck Rose and Marcus M on the team uh
it's great honestly you know um two
veteran guys who you know are very vocal
in our locker room um who has been a big
help you know from you know guys has
been here for years and you know guys
that's you know just coming in um I feel
like you know those pieces for us uh not
only on the court but off the court you
know will help us you know get better
you know all around and you know Excel
and play at a high
level Jo you talked about the support
you've received from your family from
the organization what about around the
league from fellow players have they
given you their support and also have
they given you advice as well no I
didn't talk to none of them no other
players
nah and that was kind of where I was
going like is that you know any anybody
you looking for as far as mentorship
because I'll be honest you know people
reaching out to me and like can you get
me in touch with job I'm like I don't
know J I don't talk to him like that so
I can only imagine people that's been
talking to you is there anybody that you
respect enough that you have been
talking to as sort of like a mentor uh I
feel like I have everybody around me now
that you know helped me um get to where
I want to be um no knock to anybody you
know who's want to reach out or um they
haven't been reaching out to me so um no
not to them but um I feel like you know
my family the organization uh my
veterans now on his team um is you know
all I need right
now when you talked about the learning
that you did who were you learning from
specifically or or what were there other
resources like books or classes aside
from you know people that you were
learning from uh therapy learning from
you know me obviously I feel like I
learned stuff about myself that you know
I didn't um during that you know process
um very eye opening um kind of gave me a
you know a new look you know on life uh
with you know how I go about my days how
you know I carry myself um you know just
being grateful and thankful you know
that I'm you know still here and in the
position that I'm
in J right here um couple of quick ones
but you know when this suspension first
hit it was a couple of months away where
you're going to make your return as you
sit here now just days away how how
antsy are you that it's finally here I
wish the game was just earlier and it's
me talking to y'all afterwards honestly
uh but um I can say it's been you know a
while but it kind of you know went by
fast um I feel like like I said earlier
what helped me is you know being around
the guys you know as much as I could be
um what kind of you know helped me
through this and help this you know
suspension go fast
um I've been counting down the days you
know myself I wake up every day and be
like yeah you one day closer so and and
with everything that you've gone through
and everything that's that you know is
Weighing on you as you start to play
again are you going do you have to play
are do you think there's a fine line not
on the court because you're not going to
change the way you play but with
everybody so many eyes on you now again
do you feel like there's a there's a
sense of pressure pressure off the court
that man I I just got to walk that line
and just be this NBA basketball player
and a father and with your family is is
there a difference this time than maybe
any other time you've rolled out and
played in terms of the pressure to do
right as you move
forward uh I feel like that's a good
question I honestly feel like you know I
can't go away from being J um I feel
like that's the most important thing you
know not trying to lose myself or you
know be somebody that not or you know
act totally different but the change
will be you know my decision making and
you know how I go about my daily life of
being you know a NBA player you know a
father a role model a brother a son um
and just you know focusing in on that
you know being you know the best job I
can
be uh you mentioned learning things
about yourself do you understand now why
the things that happened last year or
whatever happened I mean do you have a
better understanding of it because of of
what you've been through what's that
experience been like figuring that
out uh yes but I feel like it's still a
process um I obviously feel like you
know I'm not done yet at learning myself
or you know learning new things but um I
definitely you know see why um you know
the things happen
happen um but like I said earlier you
know I can't say I sit up here and it
because in the end I feel like it made
me
better obviously the growth you made as
a human right I can't yeah yeah the the
growth you may as a human obviously
takes priority but do you think what
you've learned about yourself over the
last year or so can help you level up on
the court even
more I'm just going on the court to be
job man uh honestly um just you know
every time and you know I step on the
floor just you know going out there and
giving my all um and focus on getting
the
win
J have you paid attention to any like
the polls the stories that just media
talk about guys who they said have
passed you since you've been going away
guys who got better than you I
personally got a little ticked off about
it because I know you still him but what
are your personal thoughts on like the
perception you've had when they say well
this guy's better than John now or this
guy's better than John who who they said
was betterton bro uh who else uh what's
to do with play for new New York Nicks
man Brunson all these dudes they saying
they better than the 12 so uh hats off
to them you know for you know leading
their teams and you know playing great
you know obviously you know the league
has you know a lot of talented players
um I have no say on you
know who's better than me and who's not
um obviously that's everybody else
opinion so um
yeah I don't get mad about that stuff
man hey you know a couple years ago you
guys always shoulder do you have that
that same Shing Edge that you I think
may have been lost the last couple years
you know
y yes a share size now not share
size thanks everyone not a little small
chip no more it's a
share